[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum thanks for uh
listening making this podcast your
choice great guest today but we got some
cool information so hopefully you'll
stick around if you're here for Alex
Winter and you just want to fast forward
I ask you not to uh and if you like this
interview I hope you'll say hey not a
bad podcast let's subscribe and write a
review maybe just follow us on our
handles which are uh inside if you put
on Twitter inside of your podcast on
Instagram and Facebook that is
exceptionally true uh we also have uh
cool merch at the inside of you online
store autographs Smallville scripts and
inside e mugs and tumblers and uh great
stuff
um Lex Luthor Funko Pops autograph it's
time it's a holiday season if you want
to get these uh also go to sunspin.com
my band sunspin our album just came out
we have new merch we have a new CD you
can get signed or not signed in a
calendar with me and all the months of
the year with Rob uh that's their mugs
tons of stuff sunspin.com and you can
use well I don't know if the code's
going to be on there so I won't say that
but anyway go there sunspin.com uh and
also Tom and I will be at uh
I guess this airs Tuesday
so we'll be in Columbus this weekend
coming
for Khan Columbus Ohio Saturday night
Smallville nights we do an event Tom and
I it's a wonderful event you'll like it
and the following week will be in
Pittsburgh signing autographs at steel
city com uh and I'm also on a cameo if
there's a Christmas you want me to say
something for Hanukkah Christmas Kwanzaa
go to Cameo get it reserved now uh Ryan
oh it was kind of cool my friend Chris
McDonald not to confused with Happy
Gilmore Chris McDonald he lives in
Atlanta he was at a comic book store
with his wife and he was like man
Rosenbaum would love this store
action figures and stuff and the owner
goes uh are you talking about Michael
Rosenbaum he's like yeah he's like you
you know him I was like yeah he's my
best friend and the guy's like
I love him
uh his podcast
he has such a soothing voice that's what
Chris told me hold on can I play the
audio just so you don't think I'm
bullshitting you can I do it sure yeah
I'm gonna do it
listen to this this is crazy I was at
old historic area
of the suburb in Atlanta called
Lawrenceville
and uh there was a cool comic and
Collective shop the guy had all these
crazy old Comics man
a crazy old collector items like
your figures the original Obi-Wan Kenobi
out of the 12 set
all this crazy stuff
and I was there with Brenda Nelson and I
was just like man you know we love this
store because they have some lunch boxes
all this stuff I said Rosenbach
owner said Roosevelt you wouldn't mean
Michael Rosenberg it was so Random I
said yeah yeah and he goes That's
the soon you met him because I'm
obsessed with this podcast and I know
in here but I know that
I said that's crazy he goes yeah man
this podcast is hands down the best
podcast out there you know there are all
these people who have podcasts and
just like to hear themselves talk but he
gets to the root of mental health and
this and that and blah blah my favorite
one he was naming his favorite episodes
and he was saying
in his voice
he has such a soothing radio voice it's
like listening to the Old School radio
host it's just like
my God
huge inside of you fan and he loves that
you're a collector and everything man
it's crazy so I just you know
I said man if he ever comes to visit me
we'll come by the store because he's
gonna love this store so the guy was
over the
huge inside of you fan out there it was
cool man
[Music]
I thought that was so cool it was just
sweet and it brightened my day that P
somebody out there was like you know I
know we have listeners and people who
are devoted and love the podcast but you
know that my friend experienced that in
Atlanta had a comic book store and it
was so Random I just I thought I got a
kick out of it I really got a kick out
of it and uh thanks Chris for
brightening my day you all brighten my
day with with messages like that
um
that's pretty much it I think we can get
into it uh we had a great podcast I've
been trying to get this guy for a while
my friend Jason Patrick who lost boys
great actor uh is friends with him they
work together on Lost Boys And um I met
him at Jason Patrick's son's concert and
I was like hey could you get Alex he's
like yeah they came over the house
and was just open willing to talk about
Lost Boys willing to talk about Bill and
Ted and Keanu and his life and what he's
doing he just it was very fun to have
him here he's iconic he's he's a legend
it was great and I think you guys are
going to really enjoy this you enjoy
this didn't you it was great yeah I I
loved it um so anyway here it is let's
get inside of Alex winner
it's my point of view you're listening
to inside of you with Michael Rosenberg
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience first of all did you notice
anything weird in this room
no though I like all the posters yeah
did you notice that one over there
uh no I didn't see that coming in I had
uh
Jason and Kiefer over here for the
podcast yeah Jason told me it was really
fun they were great they were really
great and they were keeper sitting right
in front of it he was like oh geez
you're a nerd
yeah of course you got to get in there
you know it's one of those things where
you're probably tired of talking about
everything except your awesome
documentaries it's like I don't want to
talk or do you care I don't really care
I've been doing this so long you get you
know you get not a nerd to it but
you know when you're talking to cool
people or people ask you interesting
questions or whatever there's always
something to it you know what I mean
yeah
um
you know a lot of times the Bill and Ted
questions get very repetitive but I
don't know it was a fun time in my life
so I don't normally mind talking about
any of it yeah I think if it was a
terrible time and you hated working with
Keanu and yeah and then you were like
you know I don't really you know it
would suck yeah that's the thing that
Jason and I were talking about recently
was just like we you know with the Lost
Boys thing it was such a seminal
experience and age
that we enjoy talking about we enjoyed
being together you know what I mean like
the whole gang enjoyed each other so
you've been friends since that movie
yeah I've known Kiefer and Jason since
then I mean obviously we've all gone our
separate ways
um and uh and I didn't live in it I left
La in like 93 and didn't come back until
2005. so where'd you go I had a
production company in London
and I worked out of the UK and I lived
in Upstate New York and I lived in
England
so wow I literally I just sort of hit
pause on the Hollywood were you over it
I I was I'd started it professionally at
nine years old I'd I'd worked pretty
much non-stop until I was 25.
and after Bill and Ted 2 I really I was
already directing I'd gone to film
school that was already yeah you know
making commercials and music videos and
we had a TV show on MTV and then we
eventually made a feature and after that
I was like I'm I'm out of here
um and I literally like called my agents
who were lovely and I just said look I'm
going to split because I'm not going to
go out on call so there's no point me
being at this agency anymore
um and I left
do you know I've I don't know how many
times I've thought of that I just want
to go and yeah you know I'm gonna move
back to Indiana right and then my
friend's like dude what are you gonna do
in Indiana like I don't know it's close
to stuff right Chicago and St Louis and
it's like what are you gonna do like
they got a nice drink I'll play some
men's league hockey I'll uh I'll have a
house there's Seasons yeah I'll I'll
have fall and winter and summer and
spring yeah it's just different it's
like dude you're gonna get saboro you
have no friends there I go why have old
childhood friends all right that's right
that was just lovely cops now but yeah
exactly and they always just talk talk
me out of it I mean I think I think that
if they're all like you should man I
think you'd have a really nice time and
probably listen to them yeah but I
really trust my friends even though I
get aggravated by their honest thoughts
on the whole thing yeah and like you
would just you'd go bananas yeah and I
always think that having like a a little
Lake behind you and a nice peaceful
house but then I'm like but you still
have to live with yourself you do yeah
there you are everything yeah and I love
the industry and I love what I do
um but when you start really young I
think it's kind of healthy to to have
some time away yeah I would say because
it's just a constant you know when
you're in the
the you you've never really had that
sort of
sort of regular life constant if you
start that young yeah that is a good
thing to have at some point I didn't
know you started so young I mean
I I think I probably would have gone
absolutely insane I'm a very immature
person and if um you know I didn't get
my first big thing Smallville till I was
like
27 yeah or something yeah but that was
like the big break and yeah I think that
hit me when I was nine right ten or even
15s 18. yeah I I would lose my mind I
wouldn't know what to do I didn't have
the maturity I didn't have the
wherewithal I didn't I I probably would
have gotten some trouble yeah and uh all
of those now I think I'm I think I've
ticked every box that you just mentioned
but really yeah oh sure it's inevitable
I mean it's inescapable and it's okay
there's ways of of getting through all
that but it's inescapable it's it's you
know as a director I've worked with kids
a lot and I always have and I talk to a
lot of moms you know they're always like
you know what should we do like you went
through it and I was like well you could
just pull them out you know yeah right
and you're serious that's the safest
thing you could do is you could pull
them out but if you're going to keep men
then you've got to be all over it
because it's a lot yeah for kids that
young I gotta say This is Gonna Come Off
weird you might take you might be upset
with me there's no weird question I'm
honest to God I don't envy you I'm glad
I had a childhood yeah even though
dysfunctional family and all this all
right I'm out of here I'm glad that I
wasn't
immersed in this business so early on
yeah and that I had friends that walk
around our little neighborhood and cut
through yards and drink out of garden
hoses and catch fireflies and play
Wiffle ball in the backyard and be a kid
yeah and kind of get lost and just get
in the mischief and it just seems like
you didn't have that I did actually you
do have that and the job on top of it
like I had summer camps and I had my
buddies and I had my running around back
alleys and I had all of that okay but I
had and so it's you know to to be fair
to my parents I think they thought I had
a normal childhood
but applied on top of that was I was on
Broadway and I was doing eight shows a
week including two on Saturday and two
on Sunday and two on Wednesday how old
were you here I was on Broadway from age
13 to age 17 every day wow
um
and then I was doing shows before that
and auditioning all the time and all
that from and I was doing commercials
and theater and stuff from like 10 to
13.
um
so that's like that's applied on top of
the normal life it's like you have this
life and then you have that thing on top
of the life so you know to to your point
like I think what saved my sanity was
that I had that alternative life but the
stressors of trying to manage both right
are very intense at that age yeah will
bite you on the ass on some level it's
just inescapable do you think kids when
you start acting at a young age it's
beneficial in some ways because is there
a lack of
that sort of
anxiety ridden thing that we get as
adults the older we get we care more we
we're obsessed with being great we're
like when you're a kid you sort of let
things go that's why you see some great
child actors that are just awesome and
you're like how do they do that like the
Joel what's his name Hey Joe Osmond yeah
and you're like Jody Foster or Elijah
Wood or I mean Thomas
um I think that that I mean I wouldn't
presume to speak for anyone else but
myself because everybody's different but
I think that
um for me I actually had a love of stage
which is why my parents let me do it at
a really young age I was dancing I mean
my parents were dancers but they were
modern dancers so they weren't in the
industry at all like at all at all
um but I love tap and I love theater and
I love being on stage and I'm really
young I got on stage at like five six
seven so
but I was taking dance class at three
four five six
um gosh so I was like all singing all
dancing and they were like oh my God we
gotta get out of his way and so they
didn't want to not let me do it because
I loved it so much
um and that's different like when I when
I talked to other kids uh and I made a
documentary for HBO called Showbiz Kids
yeah talked to a lot of kids for that
and there were some you know
um who were just all singing all dancing
and it made sense and like if you're
their parent what are you gonna do you
know yeah um but it's a lot for the
parent if they're if once you get into
you know if you have some success
um and so to answer your question I
don't know how much it matters I think
that for me personally my trajectory you
know I was on Broadway I got hired by
Yul Brynner I was like working with very
high and people very young but I didn't
start studying intensely until my early
20s like I had actually almost finished
my career before I was like okay now I
want to really study
and wow I you know I'd gone through Film
School even I was like no I want to work
with like really high-end method people
and they went to NYU I went to NYU for
film I didn't study acting at all at NYU
um and so I came out and I was like
I just want to train and I just started
training even when I wasn't acting
professionally so I kind of rebuilt my
own craft later uh that's rare huh which
is just a weird this is because I like
act I mean I do have the bug I love it
um you still love it I absolutely I
adore it and I'm happy to be back doing
it again I've been training like heavily
for the last 15 years training yeah
vocal physical you still do that all the
time I train all the time are you I love
it I never hear this it's one of my
favorite things to do though I think you
have to like doing it I don't think ever
I remember talking I won't name the
actor because he's a very famous actor
we're talking to a friend of mine who's
very famous and I was we were talking
about training it's like I never trained
I just hate it and I never do it and
he's got a great career so God bless him
but I I just love it I love singing
lessons I love doing Alexander training
work I love all of you do it every week
I do it all the time yeah
intensely well I mean I've seen study
you memorize lines you go in you're
always doing a scene exactly and you you
take your scenes to him to a coach to do
work on sessions yeah I do that too
um that's almost like a separate thing
but I but I'll work my auditions with my
coach but I'll just run scenes all the
time and like all through covet I was
doing like Henry V and like all this
crazy Shakespeare stuff just for fun
um you find that fun I do yeah that is
you
[Music]
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
therapy online
the amazingly talented people who appear
on my podcast and me let's be honest may
seem like we have it all figured out
but we obviously don't navigating any of
life's challenges can make you feel
unsure whether it's a career change a
new relationship or becoming a parent
unfortunately life doesn't come with a
user manual a trained therapist is the
next best thing therapists are trained
to help you figure out the cause of
challenging emotions and learn
productive coping skills which makes
therapy the closest thing to a guided
tour of the complex engine called you
as the world's largest therapy service
betterhelp has matched 3 million people
with professionally licensed and vetted
therapists available a hundred percent
online plus it's affordable just fill
out a brief questionnaire to match with
a therapist if things aren't clicking
you can easily switch to a new therapist
anytime it couldn't be any simpler no
waiting rooms no traffic no endless
searching for the right therapist learn
more and save 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
inside that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash inside
I I mean it's always a lot to me when
somebody says you have to memorize all
this and you have to it's like it's a
job yeah and you have to be great in
auditions I hate auditions like I'm not
insane I don't like I don't like
auditioning I like I like acting right
right you know if you're doing scenes
with a really great coach there's
nothing more free than that other than
doing like black box theater right or
just like come if you feel like it don't
if you don't feel like it auditioning
sucks yes and I've hated auditioning
since I was started auditioning it just
sucks are you good at it though I don't
know I mean what kind of feedback you
know I've had this these questions and
these conversations with other actors
and they're like you know
all casting directors will always give
you feedback feedback to your agency he
was great he's just he's just not
they're going in a different direction
or he's great we haven't made a decision
he's always great he's always great and
I'm like I gotta get to the bottom of
this yeah I can't always be great not
everybody's great and I talked to a
casting director and I go why do you
casting directors always say great
he was great
you know honestly it's because if that
person becomes a star or that person
became demand we want to bring them in
so they sort of lie and which it's
easier to say he did a good job but
we're not you know yeah instead of
saying your client is one of the worst
actors I've ever seen what a piece of
[ __ ] that was yeah he didn't take any
time I mean occasionally you'll get some
but like but that requires a lot of
hubris like you think about I'm reading
one of um I love reading uh uh to
Anthony shares books the you know the
the South African uh Shakespearean actor
who died not too long ago and
he was saying
um passages just reading the other day
about how he applied to every major
British acting school when he first got
to England and he was rejected like you
just said by like Radha said not only
were you terrible but you should
absolutely not act you know really 15
years later he was knighted and doing
every major Shakespeare part at the as
the you know the top actor at the RSC so
I think to be fair to casting directors
they don't know
right I think it's safer for them to say
someone was great because they don't
know you might have had a shitty day you
may be great you know I think that what
did help me being a young actor as far
as that goes with auditioning
um was I started so young and I got a
lot of affirmation from people like Yul
Brynner and folks like that were like
well like look you know you've got
something keep working on it don't
listen to anyone don't read reviews
and I that was some really good advice
just do the work that you think is good
like within yourself that's the best you
can do and I know that that's like to an
actor like you know you hear that you're
like yeah right if you have a bad day
you're like that's not going to
penetrate your head right you're just
gonna think oh I'm just I just suck
um but it does resonate in my head and
that's one of the reasons I like to
train is like if I do I might have a
shitty audition and I've just done an
amazing run with my Shakespeare
monologue with my coach and I know I
don't suck you know what I mean yeah I
just I wasn't either right for it or I
didn't hit it right or somebody was rude
in the in the casting room and it set me
off or whatever
um you know you have to have narrative
still to do any of this stuff yeah and
you have to smile and but I direct a lot
and some on the other side of that
equation a lot and it you know I I and
it helps me in my doc work a lot because
I really care about making the people
I'm working with feel comfortable and
that they can trust me and that that's
genuine and that I have their back yeah
because as an actor you often don't have
anyone who has your back yeah do you are
you do you let things go pretty quickly
like uh I learned to when I auditioned
for something I'll leave as I'm leaving
I'll take the sides and I'll just throw
them in the trash and then once I close
that door I forget about it I'm 100 that
way and often what I really try to do
and have have
and do much better as an adult than I
did when I was a young actor is I just
I'm just grateful
I mean you know I'll say this to you
because you're an actor because some
people would just think it's [ __ ]
but I'm just grateful for the
opportunity to act period for the
opportunity to explore character right
even if I'm wrong for it like that's
something that came with a little bit
more maturity like I'll read the size
I'm like that is literally the opposite
of me but this is awesome like I get to
try to figure out what version of that
character would be me I'm sure they
won't cast me because like I wouldn't
cast me for this but I'm gonna I'm gonna
have fun exploring like this weird guy
that's not at all like me and I'm
grateful for that opportunity
wow you're an anomaly well it's also I
am and I'm not I have another job you
know what I mean I have a whole other
career directing my docs and I have a
company and I'm not normally needing the
acting job to pay my bills right so and
again it's not like I'm so privileged
like I'm just like independently wealthy
I do need to work like I'm out in the
world with my family yeah I have like
life and health insurance and you know
I've never been like you know I'm not a
trust fund kid right right I'm really
not unwealthy family uh to put it mildly
so it's not like I'm Cavalier in that
way but I I feel like I'm just there to
do the best character that I can do
and I have gratitude
um to be able to find a character that I
can [ __ ] with kind of yeah you know but
to your absolutely I leave and I'm like
that's my take I'm done like if you get
it it's almost it's weird it's like when
I get things done I'm just kind of like
oh I kind of felt I did this already
like like to do it for years like I'll
just do it again you know but it was
done we did it I you know the difference
is a lot of people and I'm sure no I'm
not I'm sure I've done this but I'll be
sent something I go this is absolutely
not me they're never gonna cast me this
I'm not wasting my time I'm not gonna
sit there and we'll take three days to
learn these lines yeah and be try to be
great in something they will not cast me
in yeah so I don't do that you take the
challenge as an exercise yeah you've
always done that no I have not when I
was younger I I did not do that it made
me crazy I would read something to be
like God this is such a waste of my time
I am not going in on this there's no way
or or they could join me into doing it
and I would and I wouldn't get it and
I'd be like there's no way going to get
that
um but I was not mature you know yeah
and maybe that's my problem no I don't
know I'm not I'm not saying that's your
problem because I think I think I get a
lot of a lot of grounding from the fact
that I don't have the stakes are lower
for me because I'm usually about to
start another doc or whatever and I just
it's fine if I'm not going to get that
it's okay I have nothing to lose right
um and then I think the other thing that
helped me was because I spent so many
intervening years directing because like
the whole chunk of time when I left the
business I was directing primarily
commercials and indie films and what
kind of commercials I mean I did tons
but I do a lot of um sort of effects
driven big comedy it was in the UK so
the ads there are pretty cool and their
comedy is very smart smart and
sophisticated and oftentimes we were
building big sets and doing fun crazy
physical things wow
um and the actors are really good and
because they don't have a giant Film
Community you know you would have Terry
gilliams production designer you'd have
Kubrick's Dolly group like it was crazy
wow so the quality of the people around
me was very high and I learned a lot but
I also auditioned all the time actors
and I would watch
actors come in
who were like if I was the guy was like
I'd be like why are they even here
they're so not right for it and then
they would do something great
and they would totally turn my own
thinking around and that got me to think
you know what I don't know everything
you never know you just don't know and
it's like I would cast someone who was
so not even what I thought I was gonna
cast like that's like this is the
opposite of the type that we asked for
and then they like I'm like wow that's
such an interesting take let's go that
way or let's find something for him yeah
or exactly or absolutely next time let's
put them like this is the person who's
gonna do X so I think that's helped me a
lot now too of just like thinking and
the other aspect of that when you're on
the other side of it is like everybody's
under stress yeah you know casting's
under stress directors are under stress
everyone has a boss everyone's under
stress and that's also very that really
levels the playing field and I came back
to acting just like we're all
slugging it away together in the same
trench right yeah in the same Fox
absolutely the other side of the camera
we're on and that makes you just kind of
go you know I'm just gonna go have fun
and like do the best I can with this
character and and not sweat it did you
listen to Yul Brenner and other people
about not reading your reviews and not
he got mad it was like one of the only
times he got he was a lovely genteel
amazing guy and was one of the best
mentors I ever had and I was very young
when I worked with him
um the only time he didn't lose his
temper but the only time he kind of got
short with me was we had just gone from
Broadway we ended up out of the Pantages
on the national tour
and I got I got singled out in a really
bad review and singled out to show it no
no oh you were the bad yeah yeah as in
the show is great except the only
problem with this show are you serious
to kill you and I was 13 and I was like
you know
my first Big Show and I just come from
doing it on Broadway and it was it was
amazing but it was very intense you know
um
and I went I was really hurt and I went
to Brenner and I was like God I just got
this crushing review and he was like nut
stop stop
stop do not read the reviews do not read
the reviews you do the best you can do
I'm here to tell you you're great [ __ ]
the reviews
and I was like well okay then and that
was it for reviews no but it was it was
it was strengthening yeah you know I
understood the the note behind the note
as they say
um and I certainly take them less
seriously and now I have I honestly you
know I get reviewed all the time
especially for my film work and I I get
as much I actually like reading reviews
to see if I can mine anything
constructive from them sure sometimes
they hurt I'm not impervious to that but
I do find I get a lot out of good or bad
reviews have you ever talked to someone
who reviewed it and just be like what
what do you have something against me
what the [ __ ] why is your why would you
write this it's that bad it's kind of
like internet trolls though when you
actually meet your internet troll
they're always like super nice and like
backpedal at 100 miles an hour yeah so
anytime I've met critics like even if
they're friends of mine who have slagged
me they're always super nice and
I don't know but you you know be being
behind a pen or a keyboard is and is
emboldening yeah
Jesus man were you all I mean it sounds
like you had a pretty good upbringing
right I did you know I think my parents
my parents were crazy Bohemian artists
but they were lovely as well
um and I had a lot of admiration for
them uh are they still with us uh my mom
is my dad's been gone for a while
um he ran a dance company in the midwest
in St Louis modern dance company and my
mom was a dancer and
you know that was when I made the
zapadoc one of the reasons I wanted to
make it was I felt very a lot of
affinity for those kids not literally
because I didn't know them you know than
meeting them around Hollywood or
whatever
the house is like right yeah we should I
shot here like I was there every day for
a very long time
um
but uh but I grew up in a very similar
household with like two parents who were
very Bohemian during the sexual
Revolution and the house was a little
nuts people over mingling over all the
time waking up with naked bodies walking
around really two modern dancer parents
you know okay so naked dongs walking
around and others all these women yes
all of the above did and you were kind
of used to it you got used to it I mean
I had we were in St Louis mostly because
my mom taught at washu and it was a very
Suburban
normal existence on the one hand and a
super crazy Bohemian existence on the
other
um and so it was I mean it was an
interesting upbringing and I got an
enormous amount out of it and my parents
were very brilliant and very inspiring
but definitely crazy Bohemian folks so
it smelled like potpourri and like a
Pier One Imports no not that that
thankfully yeah no they weren't they
weren't they weren't like you know she
was a college professor at a major
university you know it's just eccentric
and yes are also free yeah yeah and I
got myself to school usually and figured
out how I was getting home and you know
at a very young so you knew your parents
were sort of sleeping with different
people and things and having fun yeah
and that didn't strike you as odd it did
but I dealt with it I mean I was a
regular super of a kid my friends would
come over be like um just don't look out
that window
because if you look out that window
you're going to see my mom and her
boyfriend naked sunbathing would people
comment you in high school like oh
there's winners family's weird no by
high school I was living I was on
Broadway and I was like I was the weird
one right
um but uh no this was like elementary
school and stuff
[Music]
inside of you is brought to you by
patreon my level of patrons go to
patreon.com inside of you it truly helps
the podcast top tiers get things like
packages sent to them every few months
Notes From Me YouTube lives
um questions with me and the list goes
on please support the podcast we
couldn't do this without you patreon.com
inside of you
good Lord yeah I used to remember
walking home thinking my mom was having
an affair and I was thinking of ways to
kill the guy if I came there and she was
with him and I was like I'm gonna kill
this guy and I'm like eight years old
walking up the street yeah and like and
you know you're just like it's just a
wow yeah but I mean it was cool that
you're just like you know you had a good
head on your shoulders I'm sure they sat
with you and said hey this is the deal
they were it was the 70s so yeah it was
all very there was a lot of talking
going on you know has she changed mom
well yeah she's in her 80s
names yeah you know nobody wants to see
that yeah yeah
I mean she's just an awesome New York
New Yorker now how old were you when
your parents divorced
eight did that affect you you think yeah
yeah for sure it did like what did it I
mean it was it was
I mean it was the 70s and it was like
you know the ice storm right it was like
everybody's parents were fighting
everyone's parents were divorcing
everybody's parents was having affairs
but you didn't want it to be your
parents you know right and uh you know
and I my parents were both really
interesting artists and I I looked up to
both of them so much
um they were both sort of like live this
what I just thought was a sort of
extraordinary life you know they were
just human beings at the end of the day
but it was so it was a little crushing
in that way where you really wanted them
to be this Allegiance yeah
um and I moved away my mom and I moved
to New York when I was quite Young when
I was 12. so I lived pretty far away
from my dad after that and how often did
you see him you know not as often as I
would have liked but you talked on the
phone yeah we were very close but uh you
know my dad was uh was a very was a very
all-in choreographer and very in his own
world and I mean I think I said this to
Ahmet or moon or someone when I was
working on zap but like
I understood coming up in a Bohemian
family where Dad was a little
unattainable right where he was cool
but unattainable and if you got to him
you usually got to him through his work
it was a bit like that so there wasn't
like any we talk about emotions or
affection did you feel like there was a
lot of affection I think there was a lot
of affection there wasn't a lot of of
committed presence like looking back on
it now because I've got three boys I
mean one of them is a stepson but I've
been with me forever yeah I met him at
the whiskey yes you did because my you
met my youngest that's my kid you met
him at the whiskey drinks yeah yeah
because uh Jason Patrick yeah mutual
friend was his son Gus was playing
Amazing just kicked out oh my God yeah
it was so great my son loved it he was
just like mesmerized they're the same
age I can't believe he could do that at
that age and be on stage like that's
that's balls and uh not Ahmed Zappa but
dweezel dweezel yeah it helps him I
think he's helping him guitar player
yeah that's incredible yeah go ahead so
I mean it's just it's you look back on
it when you've got your own kids because
I I love I just happen to love parenting
I don't think it's a job for everyone
I've told many of my friends like should
I have kids I'm like not if you don't
want them not if you don't want to be a
dad no harm her foul not doing that you
know we don't need more people who don't
want to be parents being parents yeah I
don't think my dad was cut out for
parenting you know I think my dad didn't
really know what on Earth to do with
kids so we just didn't really yeah so we
became a lot closer as I got older
um because I was an artist and he was an
artist and we just had a you know a lot
more in common but I don't think my dad
was cut out for Dad hood is is being a
father is it
how hard is it
I mean it's a job in a way right and so
it requires certain instincts I think
that come with having a job that you
like
um you know when you're an actor you
have the you know I think you you
probably tell friends of yours this who
want to act or or people that are young
that ask you about like acting
it is easy and it's really hard right it
is genuinely both of those things but if
you love it the hard stuff's okay like
it's a lot of work it makes you
vulnerable there are really bad days you
have to be at the top of your game all
the time parenting is kind of like that
if you're going to be any good at it
yeah so it's like it is a lot of work
but if you like it it's you enjoy the
work and that's kind of how I've always
felt about it
um I genuinely love I mean there are
times when I'm just like
like I want to leave the business but
like my priorities are like more my kids
than the work where I'm just like I'm
gonna like not do this job and I'm just
gonna make sure I'm with my kid like and
I've taken certain directing jobs just
to like have my kids involved and so
like I did a couple of movies Ben 10
movies for Cartoon Network because my
yeah I was going through a divorce and
my youngest my kid at the time was a Ben
10 fanatic and I was like I'm gonna just
do these Ben 10 I mean I'll have fun I
wanted to do them but like leo'll just
be able to hang out be immersed in Ben
10 get his mind off the [ __ ] that's
going on at home yeah and like he's into
Arts he could design creatures and I
don't know I just think that's if you
like being that's like my dad now never
have occurred to my dad right like
that's a different different mindset
yeah but you knew at a young age you're
already performing at a young age so you
fell in love with it were you more
because a lot of times people will say
actors will say I just want to do
theater that's all I ever wanted to do
and other people say like myself I was
like I did a lot of theater and I I just
want to do film and TV now I don't
really that's it's too much yeah do you
feel that way because you haven't done
theater in a long time right I gotta
tell you man I if I
on the acting front if I could do
anything I wanted acting wise I would
only do I would only do theater really
honest to God but it's it's I love
movies they're great TV awesome I really
do and nowadays I think some of the best
storytelling
on the planet is going on in TV just
because of the way the businesses has
evolved probably certainly some of the
best writing some of the best acting
yeah is on TV so I don't have a snob
it's not a snobbery thing but I came up
to I mean I saw I got on stage at five
you know I was on Broadway from 13 to
17. they did The King and I did Peter
Pan Peter Pan did really some really
lovely high-end Off-Broadway with some
really good directors and writers and I
miss the stage so much and I would do it
if I could but I don't I don't have any
any snow and I just love acting like I
was on a set
um because I started doing more acting
again recently I was on a set with my
friend Lexi Alexander's movie in Nevada
this thing for Netflix and I'm not the
lead I'm just a supporting character so
I was just you know as you are when
you're doing that I was sitting on set a
lot waiting to do a scene or something
on a day and just watching a couple of
actors in a pool of light Darkness all
around doing their scene very quiet
hundreds of people watching them silent
and I was like this is the best job in
the world I mean it is magic so you
really love it I do I really have a
passion for this yeah I do and I don't
it doesn't have to be theater but I I
just love I love this stage do you think
you wanted to be famous or you didn't
you didn't occur to you
I mean when we when we sleep look I'm
not going to age us but when people like
our age started there was no social
media right there was no
there wasn't gratitude there was no
exactly there was no celebrity because
you're on a TV show right like
you know like we were we were joking
around like I was on Broadway everyone
of high school because I went to a
regular public high school in New Jersey
I took the bus in every day my mom did
that intentionally so I'd have a normal
life it was a really good move on her
part I wasn't at a professional kids
school but the kids at my school didn't
give a [ __ ] right I wasn't famous I
would come out of the stage door and
sign autographs for an hour
but it wasn't I didn't go home and think
I'm famous you know I'd go home my kids
would be like winner you know I heard
you lost another soccer game because you
suck right and uh it was that was and
that was fine you know it was healthy
um so I didn't have that kind of
pressure on me even though it was on
Broadway which was a big deal in a way a
performant professionally
um so it didn't really occur to me in a
way and so when I did
Bill and Ted Like Lost Boys you know was
like mini Fame right like because when
you got that and it came out were people
starting to recognize you even the I
don't know if you talked about this with
key French oh yeah I listened to that
yeah you didn't but when I did lost boys
and they're probably too modest to talk
about this but when I did Lost Boys
it was a little different it was like a
bigger production than anything else I'd
kind of encountered and it felt special
going in
um and I know Kiefer I'm I know Kiefer
and Jason felt the same way um it was
just because of Joel because of Marion
Doherty because of Warner Brothers I
felt like wow I'm part of something a
little bigger than anything I've
experienced it was a small part so I
didn't think I was going to be famous
off of that role I didn't have any idea
the film was going to have the legs that
it's had
um but it but it felt special you know
I'm sure Smallville was the same it's
part of something that feels like this
is good when you get a break you kind of
know it's a break yeah you know that
feeling like you're kind of like oh this
is different this is like not the same
[ __ ] that I've experienced before
um and so you know your life's going to
change in some little way yeah uh and I
just knew it and uh yeah me too I feel
like most the time you're like going I I
don't know I hope this is good yes I I
hope I hope it turns out really yeah
great I hope this is but when you're in
something that you sort of innately
you're like I just know this is good
yeah it's a shift right it's weird it's
a weird shift yeah wow I'm on something
that people will see yeah and it's not
here I mean for me it wasn't like uh I'm
so great or anything it was just like
you're like you've been invited onto a
bus or a train that's just riding on a
on a really sweet track and you just
know it yeah and uh so I kind of knew it
with lost boys that that that that was
kind of cool but I wasn't gonna get
famous I mean I was gonna have like you
know people like on the subway going yo
Lost Boy right like that was gonna
happen right
um but when Bill and tick came out it
was it was a it was not like nothing I'd
ever experienced and I realized at that
moment that I had not ever really wanted
that kind of public scrutiny you realize
you didn't want that you really wanted
it wasn't like I was I wasn't
ungrateful for it I was really grateful
for how well the film the film did and I
was really grateful for the response to
our performances so it's kind of a weird
abstract thing almost it wasn't like oh
Fame please go away it wasn't like it
wasn't it wasn't like that but it was
just like oh [ __ ] now like everywhere I
go in the world people know who I am all
the time like 24 7. and what would
people say to you I mean people gen
honestly because the roles are so sweet
they're generally super great like it's
it really wasn't a hassle in that way
like every once in a while you'd walk by
a frat house where everyone was wasted
and they would like chase you doing air
guitar and like that that was a pain in
the ass right
yeah but that was nothing like the
northern people like oh you know
whatever they come up and they you know
be really sweet if they say lines the
movie I could care less
um but it was a shift in that now I sort
of was like oh this is what Fame is I
guess you know and I'd watch Jewel
Brynner and I'd watch I'd been around
famous people doing the Broadway shows
people who were really famous not just
us doing you know the the roles that we
had
um
and it was suddenly it was weird to be
in that zone yeah did you audition for
that I did yeah just like anyone else
how many times a gazillion really over
Canada when I auditioned oh we we
auditioned together the first time right
and then we got split off and then we
were auditioning against other people
for a really long time and then we they
pulled us back in and they did this
weird Marathon day like I'm not even
sure like the Unions would allow it
anymore because it's really kind of like
that movie They Shoot Horses Don't They
a little bit right it was so kind of
sadistic and weird but like they did
this like eight hour audition where like
they just had all of the different build
and tabs that were left auditioning
until they were just they were just
literally walk out and get rid of the
ones they didn't want until it was
literally just like three of us left was
it intimidating it was depressing
because these were all of your friends
like you know what it's like talking
like this this is your friend group
you know when you're young like when
you're in your 20s in La none of you are
from La like I was from New York Keanu
was from Toronto no one else was from
here right so we were all buddies
because we were like all like had PTSD
together yeah work in the audition
circuit and moved living in some
[ __ ] and wherever we were
um and then one by one they started like
you know coming out and shooting them in
the head like you know and then it was
like Jesus uh and then there was like
maybe it wasn't enough of us left to
think we had it which was even weirder
it was like maybe three of us were all
like eyeball it was like the end of like
the hateful eight or something they're
like oh
eyeballing each other like all right
well there's two parts here there's
three of us that's not gonna work but I
don't know maybe none of us are gonna
get cast Hollywood's [ __ ] weird you
know what other stars were up for this I
really don't remember you don't remember
any guys that were in the room I mean I
only know because it's gotten written
about since then that like Paulie Shore
went out for it or different people say
they went out for it
um I I can't remember I mean it was it
was a lot of a lot of my friends a lot
of people from the business that I knew
and
um there was one actor who I don't I
don't remember his name because I didn't
actually know him who was like
who was really really good actually
um in my opinion like how to I'd be the
director I probably would have cast him
instead of one of us who didn't end up
getting it for some reason but uh it was
a weird painful strange process but it
was you know auditioning is it's it's
hard it's like an honest to God like now
these guys are all like my closest
friends like Chris and Ed and Scott the
producer and like Steve Herrick like
Steve was 27 years old you know Chris
and Edward when I was auditioning I
thought oh these are the grown-ups they
were maybe two or three years older than
me they how old were you
22 maybe wow Keanu was 23. and did you
know how soon after that audition that
final with all the did you know not for
a while I think what they did cattle and
I were talking about this recently
trying to patch it together he's got a
better memory than I do mine is all
effed up but
um he's like that brother you had the
like correctionals I'm like I remember
when he's like no actually what we did
was blah blah
um
no but he was like his memory I think
was that they called us into Interscope
and then they told us there and I do
remember I've told the story a trillion
times it's not fresh anymore but I do
remember vividly that day of being in
the office as an Interscope and I knew I
had the part and Keanu was all forlorn
and we'd kind of become friends by then
because we'd been auditioning for so
long and he played the bass and road
motorcycle and I played the bass and
wrote a motorcycle he just became
buddies but uh he was all for long I was
like what's your problem he's like well
I'm playing Ted and I thought it was
Bill you know and I was like dude
there's honest to God there was no
[ __ ] difference between these two
characters I'm happy I'm more than happy
to swap well he's like no no it's cool
that's also very again it was like he
didn't want to like randomly that's good
I'm good I'm good
um but uh that's amazing I think that's
when we kind of got told yeah wow and
house again did you know that this was
did you think okay this is something
special
I just know Lost Boys was the movie
where I was like wow I'm in a big hit
movie with this giant director and like
you know Jason was amazing and kiefers
have made like these actors who were so
good and I came from New York theater
and so I knew Ed Herman already I've
done yeah Manhattan theater Club I knew
and I knew Diane a little bit I knew
Bernard Hughes from the New York theater
scene I was just like these were Titans
of like New York Theater which was my
scene I was like what the [ __ ] are they
even doing here you know in this movie
with the oiled up sax player and
um so no I on Lost Boys I was like wow
this is Hollywood yeah like I'm in a
Hollywood movie you know and I'd be
doing scenes with Keith and I'd be like
God he's [ __ ] great you know he's
like he's gonna be a giant movie star
yeah and of course he was
um Builder was like the opera house yeah
I don't know I'd be like dude we'd be
like literally waiting for a take to
start looking to be like no one's ever
gonna see this [ __ ] movie you thought
that no one is ever in a million years
ever gonna see this [ __ ] movie and we
had a BL like we didn't disparage it
like we were having it we tried you
kicked out we were like but like Steve's
in his 20s and the writers are in their
20s and like no one gave it was this
weird Indie movie that no one gave a
[ __ ] about it and no one in town knew
about it was low budget and it was like
you get paid much we didn't get paid
hardly I got paid 65 000 for Bill and
Ted for three months before before
commission and tax and everything I
think I I think that money was spent
like on paying back my student loans
buff and didn't touch my rent right
um so it was like this is great we're
having we put our all into it we had fun
acting yeah we cared about it we thought
the writing was [ __ ] awesome we
thought Steve was great but we didn't
think it was the era of HBO like we were
like this is going to be on HBO at like
four in the morning like this is gonna
be sandwiched between like some TNA
horror movie goodbye Emmanuel exactly
yeah no one is ever and then sure enough
the movie the movie got scrapped so we
recall we we got a call from Scott the
producer going it was just like after we
made it after they put it but it's like
sorry guys but no one's ever going to
see this film it's being shelved and we
were like oh okay
and I went did a little like period oops
holy [ __ ] sorry it's the ghost of uh of
Dino De Laurentiis I went and did this
little movie in Italy
um after that with Laura Dern and Eric
Stoltz
and they were like and we shot some of
the same locations we just done Bill and
Ted we shot in the same castle that I
did the the Darth Vader fight with and
now I'm like playing this you know 19th
century strange character with like in
these fineries and all of the Bill and
Ted's signs were up and and they were
like what is this [ __ ] movie I was
like no one's ever gonna see this film
right
um and it got shelved and it sat on a
shelf for a year and then it got bought
out at like in a fire sale by Nelson and
then then it became a hit so it was a
very not Hollywood not we're gonna make
it
trajectory and it wasn't until the
release weekend when there was like a
two-fold ad and variety that showed me
and Keanu sitting on top of piles of
cash and it was like Bill and Ted giant
hit or whatever the wording was and I
was like oh okay but it took all the way
up until then to think it was going to
have any kind of life and they probably
worked on your deals for the next one
right away they're like yeah we started
talking to this about a sequel because
it was it had been two years because it
you know took us took them a year to
post and then it sat for another year so
that's why there's a gap between the two
and you and Ken are still close friends
yeah super I mean I you know I love him
dearly he's like Isn't that cool I mean
I have some of those from from working
with people in the past not a lot I
don't I don't have a lot you know you
don't have a lot like you could become
very bonded with a lot of folks on set
and then you know kiss kiss goodbye yeah
just and it's not it isn't it seems to
the outside world to be disingenuous it
kind of it isn't you really do care
about them while you're working but you
don't stay connected right uh yeah I I
and I worked with piano I worked with
him on a movie called Sweet November for
a couple weeks I remember that movie and
he was this I played a transvestite and
he was awesome the sweetest I mean I I
Rave about him he is just like I was
like can I call you can too and he's
like you can call me whatever
you know whatever you like and he was
just so sweet and it was like it was so
humbling that such a huge movie star is
you know you hope that they're cool you
hope and sometimes they're not yeah your
heroes are not like but he genuinely I
feel like that yeah he's he is a
genuinely good guy but you know it's
it's we came up doing theater yeah we
came from crazy artists families we both
love good playwriting and good novels
and we just have a lot in common off
screen right
um but I'm you know I'm happy that he's
kept his sanity through the Journey that
one has were you surprised that he
wanted to do the Third installment no
because we all developed it together
um so you were like it was a great
process we were having a barbecue at my
house the night Kristen had pitched it
to us so we're just all we've all been
friends forever wow so we were just at
my place eating steak that I had cooked
and Chris and I were like we got an idea
for and that was a dozen years before we
made it so it tells you how hard that
tells you like how little interest there
is in Hollywood for Bill and Ted movies
usually that's crazy so yeah did you
really were you at first when you first
kind of pitched it where you're like ah
come on no it's kind of the inverse
because those guys don't none of us
more of the mindset that we were ever
going to make a third so it was not
joking that it was almost like we have
this idea
for how to bring the guys back if
anybody wanted to bring them back and we
actually all thought it was a great idea
it was a sort of like
A Christmas Carol thing of just like
what if Bill and Ted you just come in on
them right now in their lives and they
are exactly the age they're at and their
dads and they're not trying to be 16 and
they're failures and they have to go
find the song they were supposed to
write in all these different iterations
of space-time
and we were like that's a great idea
because it's you know you must be a good
actor greedily the first thing you think
is like can I actually play this right
yeah when you hear an idea like is this
do it like can I do this without oh
making a complete ass of myself yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah like it's playable
right because I just get to be me I
don't have to try to be bill at 16 or
whatever
um it's ludicrous and it has heart and
so I think we thought look if we can
pull it off and we all produced it so it
wasn't like we all then had to go to
work and like you know Reeves is is
you know I don't want to you know I
don't wanna
talk about him in ways he probably
doesn't like being talking about but
he's he's very good at producing you
know it's like you don't get to be on
that level like you know you know
there's any of the folks you meet who
who act on that level they're not just
actors you know they're producers
they're writers they don't take credit a
lot but they're like they're in their
writing scenes they're they they know
what the director needs to do like
they're they're very hard working in
that way yeah and getting three off the
ground was very hard work for all all of
us was it fun though it was super fun
and it was lovely and it was it was our
own animal to play with so it wasn't
like drudgery but it wasn't easy yeah
how did you I know because you were
always directing you went to film school
at a young age or doing that when and
you and I know you directed freaked I
co-directed with Tom Stern right with
Tom Stern you're a good buddy from New
York that you guys became friends and
moved out to LA and we're doing tons of
shorts and things like that and working
together but you um
you were you started doing commercials
and things like that yeah but did you
always think because freak was like
again reviews were awesome and then it
became a cult hit and then Entertainment
Weekly called it top 10 comedies of the
90s yeah that had to feel really good
yeah it did because the film was hard to
make and it didn't get a big release
because it was very weird and it got
sort of caught up in a in a changeover
at the studio
um but it was great to make and I love
the the life that it has today uh but I
knew I was gonna stop acting for a beat
when that was done and I didn't act
again for over 10 years like 15 years I
don't think did it upset you is that
what it was no I was done after Bill and
Ted 2 I kind of acted and freaked
because it got it helped get it made
um because it was come we sort of
capitalized on the success of Bill and
Ted to get the film financed
um I mean Ricky is honestly the least
interesting part I mean it's it's
Elijah's movie in my opinion so it's
Randy quay's movie right
um but it got the film made so uh I knew
I was done I knew I needed a break but I
knew I was going to come back to acting
at some point I just didn't know when
right but you started doing
documentaries like the last how many
years you've been doing this about a
dozen now about 12 years and how many
documentaries have you done
I'm crappy at stuff like this I'd say
seven maybe eight I mean
it seems to me tell me I'm wrong that
making a documentary is actually harder
than making a film it's almost like you
know the ending but you don't exactly
know the ending in the beginning how are
you going to start this movie and things
change constantly and then you find that
information which changed is the arc or
whatever storyline it seems like it's a
lot of tedious work it's it's if you
like research it's not tedious you love
research I love research and if you like
your subject it's not tedious because
you're just doing a deep dive into that
subject and you live with that subject I
would say I'm I consider myself a
character actor and I've always liked
researching characters
um and it's been a very similar
discipline for me as character acting
work you know you just you when you're
when you're acting you know this you
know where you're going in terms of the
script obviously but the whole secret to
acting is to unlearn that right like is
to have spontaneity and to sort of not
know where you're going and docs are
very similar in that way so I was I
found myself more attuned to them than I
thought I was going to be like oh I can
do this like research the [ __ ] out of it
and I just trust the process is going to
take me where I need to go just just
like acting right you know so it's more
similar to acting than it is to
directing narrative wow I never looked
for me yeah yeah well I've never done it
so I wouldn't know yeah the Panama
papers trust machine the the Frank Zappa
documentary which it was the first time
the family gave you like personal like
Archives of and I mean they must have
really trusted you like a lot of time I
did two things one is I was willing to
walk away happily Gail's tough customer
and I didn't I didn't walk in with any
arrogance that she was gonna say yes so
I was ready to just walk away
um but I also I was willing to sort of
earn her trust and to explain what my
vision was and and it happened to align
with more of their sentiments which I
didn't know going in because I didn't
know what their sentiments were so that
was just the luck of the draw when
you're it's like auditioning and you get
the part it's that sort of thing of like
you happen to be what they're looking
for right you know man it's it's just
awesome I mean what got you really into
so fascinated with the internet and
because it is fascinating yeah but like
you really break it down like you
started to get into the web and and all
this stuff and Napster and all these
things throughout the last decade right
yeah and it just fat you that was where
your focus completely went yeah I found
myself
um
you know when I got out of the public
eye in 93
um I really wanted out of the public eye
I really wanted privacy
um and I thought this was kind of a
weird thing until I met Will Wheaton and
I his story is so similar to him he was
in the podcast he's amazing amazing yeah
he's so smart and such a lovely human
being but he did something similar to
like I once I started interviewing child
actors from my doc Mara Wilson similar
uh not the internet per se but like sort
of leaving the industry intentionally
sort of gathering herself finding her
own her own vision and coming back will
did go into technology in a much more uh
professional way than I did but will and
I both kind of found the internet as a
refuge from the public eye
and that's a very similar thing that I
found real simpatico with him on because
I found these internet communities in
the 80s
that were even before I was while I was
still acting where I just felt
comfortable I was Anonymous I could
speak freely I was not known I was not
seen I didn't know there were internet
communities there were there was no web
yet so they were like sort of BBS
usednet groups and and they looked like
text groups basically but they were
robust there were thousands of people
there you'd make friends you could share
content just like what you could end up
doing just over dial up so for me the
internet was a refuge it was a place to
go where I felt sort of safe and
Anonymous and that grew into all the
technology stuff uh the Youtube effect
doc yeah that's the next doc that's
coming out this Bermuda Tribeca and got
great reviews yeah we've done good so
far thank God the film takes viewers on
a timely and gripping Journey inside the
cloistered world of YouTube and parent
Google
how much again how much research on this
a lot just watch the trailer guys for
this the YouTube effect it looks amazing
I can't wait to see where will it be
coming out
um I'm not allowed to mention the
distributor reactions we're closing our
deal right now but it will be coming out
we will be mentioning that very soon
um and it will be coming out in early
2023 like in the right after New Year
basically what's your handle by the way
they could always follow you you should
follow him anyway yeah I'm um I'm winter
on Twitter so that's easy winter on
Twitter yeah just my name winter oh just
at winter yeah just at winter at winter
you got that yeah it wasn't taken no
they I didn't seek it out they actually
I was working on I think it was on Bill
and Ted press right and one of the
lovely people from Twitter film or
whatever like you know Winter's
available do you want it I was like sure
I'll take it
um wow uh and then I'm on Instagram I
think I'm Alex Winter without I think
it's Alx w-i-m-t-e-r
um so I'm those I mean I mostly Twitter
is kind of where I I hang out but it's
pretty easy to find my stuff and we will
definitely be blasting that out what do
you want to do next is it another dock
is it a feature film do you want to go
back in the feature films I'm developing
a feature I'd really like to do
um feature the feature world as you know
now is pretty difficult it's either
superheroes yeah occasional horror movie
or docs and this is an indie drama so
like you know good luck I'll probably be
back with you in 10 years talking about
the same project man I left yeah exactly
yeah yeah I'm still working on that I
have not given enough hope
um but I'm always developing docs I have
more docs I'm developing and I'm acting
um I just uh produced a film that I
co-starred in uh for shutter I love
shutter yeah with Jonah Ray Rodriguez
what is it uh it's called destroy all
neighbors and I'm is it on shutter now
no we just finished shooting so it won't
be out probably till next destroy all
neighbors is it really dark it's a
horror comedy and it's very much a
comedy with her
um I play a character buried under
prosthetic makeup um amazing so I don't
look anything like how hard is that I
love it so I get claustrophobic I don't
think thankfully yeah I really do enjoy
it which I think is probably not
mentally right I think your response is
the correct one the healthy one yeah
yeah yeah yeah but I I do intend to do
more acting
um and I'm yeah I'm developing a bunch
of stuff but we're looking we're always
doing docs so we're we're looking at the
next what's your favorite doc of all
time or top three
um that is really hard did you see the
one which takes place in 1969 and it's
like uh a boat race across the world or
around the world or whatever and like
this one guy who's more like a weekend
sailor it's called Deep Water I think
and he gets on there and
craziness ensues like you know where is
he what is he doing wait a minute he's
leading the pack people leave at
different times it's a matter of how
long it takes you it's breathtaking it's
fantastic yeah it was like um
yeah that's amazing I love I mean I love
a lot of old docs I love
um uh Gimme Shelter and yeah I love
Harlan County USA I love a lot of the
political docs
um uh Brett Morgan's new Bowie dock is
amazing is that good it's really really
good it's it's you know also full
archive access
um so he really had a deep dive and I
know from personal experience how hard
that is to shape story out of that much
media
um that's it's a really beautiful film
The Beatles doc was great amazing that
was that's nine hours very moving I want
it to be 20 hours yeah really moving I
just think to watch artists at work like
that and and to see the struggles and to
see the spontaneity and to see songs
just get pulled out of thin air
um amazing I love when George Harrison
in the middle of it says they're all
talking they're gonna take a lunch break
and George just goes okay I think I'm
gonna quit now I'm gonna quit the band
you're like what he just walks out yeah
you're like holy [ __ ] yeah and Ringo
comes off the best yeah like Ringo's
just like what are we doing yeah
whatever yeah and yoko's just sitting
there weirdly yeah like what is she
doing yeah isn't anybody getting annoyed
while they're trying to come up with
stuff yeah and she's just staring and
sitting there like it's just so weird
yeah but it's it's great and you realize
no Ringo no band right like I mean you
just watch him hold like quietly without
ego just hold that whole damn thing
together it holds it together I never
had as much respect yeah for him as I do
after watching yeah me too like he's
hilarious like yeah he's like this is
like a genius you know all right this is
this is quick this is uh
it's my Patron my patrons you have a
patron account uh yeah I do you do yeah
where can they go to support you oh no I
don't have my own you know I just I just
follow and and support folks on it oh
but this supports the podcast go to
patreon.com inside of these are the top
tiers they get to ask questions so here
we go [ __ ] talking with Alex winner
big Stevie W this is rapid fire what had
a bigger effect on your career Lost Boys
best vampire movie ever or Bill and Ted
Bill and Ted yes yeah Brandi D was it
easy for you to jump back into your
character and sync back with piano uh
you sync back with Keanu yes jump back
into character did actually take an
enormous amount of work but it was fun
but it wasn't easy per se what did you
do did you have to like just watch a
year I didn't actually I was afraid I'd
mimic myself too much but I did a lot of
a lot of physical work just trying to
find this guy's body he's they're
strange guys did you make yourself laugh
yes did you laugh on set together
constantly constantly it's clowning who
makes who laugh more uh I don't know I
don't want to be immodest and say I make
Keanu a lot more because I laughed my
ass off the whole time but at the end of
the first week we looked at each other
and we were like because we hadn't acted
together in so long we just hang out it
was like it's really fun
acting together we really enjoyed it
it's genuinely enjoyed it yeah we just
rip we finish each other's sentences
it's just it's just it's like being in a
band where you like where you Groove is
he sort of like Uncle Keanu to your kids
oh yeah yeah they all know him yeah he
comes and visits yeah yeah it's always
fun to sort of watch them get old enough
to realize who he is because they never
have no [ __ ] idea otherwise only get
to a certain age you're like oh [ __ ]
it's that guy oh really so but then he's
been around like forever too late yeah
Leanne what was it like working with
George Carlin did he correct any jokes
when the camera wasn't rolling not at
all he was very somber offset very seems
like that I watched the George Carlin
documentary that Judd Apatow just
produced yeah lovely man but not like a
yuck it up guy at all kind of dark huh
uh dark and just very somber you know
very sober quiet guy were you bummed no
I liked that because he was just so he
was so he was very sincere and open he
wasn't cold he was very very warm he was
just quiet did he ever want to like go
hey get my number let's keep in touch we
did we did kept in touch with George you
did yeah yeah we both did yeah that's
cool that is really cool uh Danny
awesome freaking guest she says about
you sweet are there any directors in
particular that influenced Alex's own
style as a director oh God so many man I
mean geez like all the way from chaplain
to David Lynch right I mean there's just
so many great filmmakers out there who's
your favorite director of all time you
have to narrow it down uh probably Orson
Welles Orson Welles yeah or Curacao one
of the two we're just talking about
kirasawa yeah our last guest was talking
about kirasawa yeah uh what about
Kubrick I love Kubrick I mean you can't
not love what's your favorite horror
movie of all time uh the thing you have
the poster here signed by Kurt the
carpenter thing would be my favorite oh
man how bad was that yeah it's just you
it's not ever not great no matter when
you watch it it's one of those the best
scene is when they're checking the blood
amazing right and they get to the one
guy and you get me out of this [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh my God it's the best right it comes
out of nowhere I'm talking about a film
that's like theaters I mean it's like
watching a Broadway play it's like 12
Angry Men with Gore yeah and what's his
name was in it the guy who goes if
you're suffering from diabetics get
yourself some quakeros that's a good one
well for Brimley Wilford Brimley yeah
yeah oh my gosh Raj tell me about a time
you struggled to keep control of a set
and how you were able to work through it
oof
um gosh that has happened all the time
um
you know there are times when you're at
your best
and you do that and there are times when
you are not at your best when you do
that one it's two o'clock in the morning
and you're very tired
uh have you raised your voice I have and
it's always the biggest bummer for me
because I don't like it you don't like
yelling I don't like it I don't want my
my ads doing it I don't want anyone on
set doing it so when you do it you're
like oh right I'm a human being
um now will you get me out of this
[ __ ] chair exactly right that's it
yeah that's amazing yeah uh DJ Kento I
want to know about shooting freaked what
was it like that movie is becoming more
and more cult lately and I love it oh
that's very sweet uh it was amazing we
were 25 years old we'd never shot 35 mil
before we were making a big Studio Movie
with an incredible cast with an army
encampment of like four different giant
makeup effects companies that each
required massive tents it was like
working on a circus
um with Randy Quaid who was like you
know one of the great actors and
it was just like a pinch yourself thing
every day it really was it was some it
was hard as hell you know and I was in
all that makeup which was hard I wasn't
getting any sleep and the thing was
ripping my mouth apart whatever but it
was an extraordinary experience Randy
Quaid yeah did you see sort of like if
you look back can you see like I could
see how that happened yes was it you can
what was it about him that when you were
watching him that was just a little bit
I love him and I don't know him well
enough to like be presumptuous about
what's going on right right but I could
see the beginning of what was going on
in there
um there's just like and it's it's
he's so good he's such a talented actor
he's such a smart guy he has such a
great imaginative
Instinct creatively like when you're
working with when you're acting with him
he's just gonna go somewhere you're not
quite expecting but there was always
that kind of like it could careen off
the tracks at any second feeling which
in our film was exactly what the
character is Right In fact I mean
Kareem's off the tracks right
um but he was very controlled but there
was always that like
you know sometimes you being a team and
be like wow like this guy like any any
none volume number higher and it's going
to almost be scary you know really and
like his views and things like that do
you remember them being none of God
nothing nothing like that no not
ideologically just just behaviorally
right yeah I do a lot I mean he was a
very very smart interesting I always
loved Randy Quaid yeah he wasn't like he
wasn't in the least bit sort of
off-kilter in his ideology when I was
working with him who is who have you
been Star Struck by
well I started very young so I was Star
Struck by Yul Brynner you know who hired
me he because he was really directing
those shows he just didn't take credit
so he was at my audition he hired me he
worked with me did you love Westworld
and I loved Westworld and I loved King
and I I loved all that stuff
um you know Sandy when I went and did
Sandy the show with Sandy was kind of
the same thing and then you start to you
know realize that they were just human
beings but
um there's been you know there's been
actors I've worked with that have just
kind of like you just go oh [ __ ] you
know yeah I'm working with this person I
felt that way a little bit with Bernard
Hughes like with some of the really big
theater folks that I've worked with we
were just like wow these are just Titans
right
um I don't often feel that way anymore
because I've just been around the
industry so long you don't get
intimidated I don't really we're all
we've all kind of been in it and I know
how hard the whole game is from all
sides and that everybody's a person
trying to like move along and survive
you know yeah so I don't usually get
intimidated unless someone's a bully
yeah you know have you had that of
course what do you do how do you deal
when I was younger I would sort of shut
down and kind of you know just avoid the
hell out of them today I'm just you know
you you deal with them like you would
somebody who flips you off in a traffic
and infraction right well what do you do
say [ __ ] you back no you said you try to
minimize the situation and and so you do
conflict resolution of the best of your
ability if it doesn't work then you tell
them to [ __ ] off I guess that's right I
guess so that's that's door number three
right yeah I guess that is door number
three I mean it's happened in my career
have you ever told someone off no not on
set I just think I don't want to do yeah
yeah you know what I mean it's like I
don't want to have that color my own
experience yeah you know do you get any
anxiety sure of course do you deal with
anxiety yeah I mean I meditate every day
every day I'm that guy yeah every
morning that's what I've been doing for
the last six weeks yeah I think it has
been helpful it's hugely helpful I've
been doing that for a long time it's
very very helpful
um and so yeah of course there's a
there's a million different things that
one you know a lot of you know very I
work out a lot and very into diet and
exercise and all that kind of stuff
vegan vegetarian I'm not no I would love
to say I was I think we're all headed
that way but I'm not
what do you eat every day like for
breakfast what would someone like you
eat
um I'm normally eating like like a
protein shake or something relatively
healthy in the morning not a heavy carb
load and you really yeah and you make
your own shakes I make my own shakes and
then for lunch like salad maybe again
not a heavy if like if I'm gonna have
carbs I'll try to do that at lunch but
not a lot because then I'm bogged down
for the rest of the day my wife makes
fun of me because like when I'm on set
I'll often tell the Caterers like don't
overdo turkey because I don't want like
the whole crew like zonked out on
tryptophan yeah oh [ __ ] and uh so those
things I think they matter I grew up
with ADHD and like I so I learned you
know what I need what my brain chemistry
needs to to be at its best and diet is
very important for ADHD do you want your
kids to act uh I do not you know
honestly don't care what they do after
college but I really don't how old they
know well my eldest just graduated
college he's a painter he just graduated
from Art School amazing really great
he's really they're all really lovely my
middle kid is uh jazz trumpet he's at
college right now for jazz trumpet wow
um and my youngest thankfully is just a
snot-nosed kid who likes to play you
know on on Discord
um and I'm very grateful for that and
none of them are in the business you
play instruments I played bass for many
many years that's right yeah and then I
had kids and I was like I just want to I
because I do too many things I need to
stop something's got to fall off the
truck did you and Kano ever play
together all the time no way all the
time still
we haven't he busts my chops for not
having a base anymore so do my kids if I
had a base we'd be playing still we used
to I mean it was really hilarious but
all through Bill and Ted one we had
condos on on you know one over the other
and we would just go and jam on Dual
bass every night after we shot wow and
uh we just jammed and jammed did you
ever play songs like covers
um yeah we would play stuff but like we
were both playing bass right so you
can't really you know it's kind of
they're a little limited
yeah but just going back and forth yeah
it was usually jamming or you have like
a song on that you're jamming to or
whatever he never you never hear about
Canada or you like you ever getting in
trouble really we were pretty I mean
we're both very we're both very into the
work you know yeah I really do love the
work I mean I love the work and um you
never let alcohol or drugs get an
interfere with that not in that way I
mean not that one has a choice right I
think right you know I don't really view
it as you know I don't really view
addiction as as a choice obviously but
um you know I look I've lived life and
I've dealt with my my life and I've
gotten to a point in my life and my age
where were all as well yeah and all is
not always well and and life sends you
on curves and you've got to adjust to
them and I've certainly had plenty of
those man you I wish I got to see things
the way he does life I mean I just you
just I mean you've done it you've done
it and you're doing it and you're still
excited and passionate about all of it
yeah I'm great I'm grateful for that I
guess I am like I I do feel very
fortunate I'm sure you do too it's like
it's a tough business and to be in it
and do things in it
you know you feel very you have a lot of
you end up with a lot of gratitude on a
good day yeah you know I feel very
grateful that I've gotten to do the
acting I have and the directing I have
and it's a crazy business you know
check out the documentaries the YouTube
effect comes out sometime in the next
couple months early 2020 early 2023 it
looks awesome watch the trailer the
YouTube effect also the Zappa what it's
called Zappa it's called Zappa it's on
Hulu the doc on Hulu yeah uh what else
should they say
um well there's a lot out there Panama
papers is on Hulu Showbiz Kids is on HBO
um besides YouTube effect that's out
what's your favorite doc that you've
done you're like this is my best word
um I really they're like I love them all
like I mean Zappa is probably creatively
the most satisfying Showbiz Kids is
thematically the most personal it was
almost an autobiography
um and that's you know in my heart
that's kind of like my favorite I'm just
so grateful that I got to do that
um talk about the industry from within
the industry in such a in such a
everyone was so vulnerable yeah
um but uh but look I'm really proud of
these things I've acted and that are
coming out the thing I did for Lexi this
movie absolute Dominion for Netflix
that'll come out next year and Destroy
absolute Dominion yeah it's it's really
cool on Netflix yeah all right and you
just go to at winter and you know you'll
find follow-up of him promoting it and
what else uh the other movie
all neighbors will come out destroy all
neighbors it's a lot of fun on shutter
yeah you know I have shutter yeah
um this has been a real treat I
appreciate you coming over and uh
I feel like I know you yeah man yeah
well we're in the same Foxhole right
yeah I'm gonna bring you a bass guitar
and we're gonna Jam all right we'll get
Gus yeah let's do it let's do it yeah my
kids are already pissed I don't play So
It's gotta get back into it I do yeah
it's time good seeing you you too man
all right
yeah I I love his stories and you can
tell he's very fond of Keanu yeah you
know just a good friendship they've had
over the years and yeah he uh what did
he say is his son's like piano's godson
I believe yeah because we just didn't
listen to it right now but something
like that or it calls him Uncle Kiana or
something like that you'll yeah I'm sure
if you listened you'll know and you're
telling me I'm wrong I wonder if I
didn't bring it up because it might be a
project he wants to forget but uh
because he's doing that whole
documentary on on YouTube and like the
Tech world yeah and all that um but he
directed uh a movie for Smosh the
YouTube personalities while I was while
we were all working at the same company
called defy media which went defunct in
2018. yeah
um
but it was like it was a movie like it
was just these two guys from Sacramento
who have been doing YouTube videos
forever and they have like a social
media Empire and they made a movie
it's not great right but uh Alex Winter
directed it really he did and I wonder
if that got him started on his um or if
that was part of his quest to uncover
some YouTube comparisons because he was
deep in it and it was like a that was
that was an interesting company and he's
a great director his doctor just
exceptional yeah so uh you know and look
I'm sure you're gonna do some stuff
that's just like you know not mainstream
or a little bit whatever but uh it was
interesting I didn't bring it up because
I didn't he might want no one he might
not want everybody I don't want to
remember that one but you know what we
all remember our you know things that
didn't you know I love my movie back in
the day I think it's hilarious a lot of
people love it but then there's half
that probably don't I think it's too
raunchy it's too whatever
I made the movie I wanted to make
you know and I learned from it and
that's all you can do that's good that's
all you can do is learn yeah learn from
your mistakes
yeah
huh anywho uh I hope you guys like that
um
uh subscribe write a review tell us what
you think follow us on the handles and
um I think that's it we're going to the
cons so look on Twitter Columbus this
weekend uh then Pittsburgh we're doing
Smallville nights come join sunspin.com
the new album get it signed uh we'll be
streaming eventually but if you want a
cool Keepsake autographed or not it's
there go to the inside of you online
store for cool merch and all that thanks
for all of you and your listening
listenership
uh really appreciate it uh we went to a
concert the other night we went to the
Depeche Mode cover band I dragged about
15 friends well it was fun wasn't it it
was fun yeah I mean it's just I'm never
gonna seek out Depeche Mode
independently so that for me was like
going to a Depeche Mode concert that's
as close as I'm gonna do right so yeah
it seemed like everybody had a really
good time it was fun we had like a nice
little space yeah except one friend I
won't say who it is but he was
on a date oh no
yeah don't say his name I don't know I
heard though yeah but on a date
and he says I'm gonna go to the bathroom
and he goes to the bathroom
and he comes back and she's gone and he
texts her and says hey where are you she
says I'm in an Uber I had to leave
just left just sucked yeah I had a
really weird thing too
um
so I went and
bumped into my ex-girlfriend
and I thought we were on great terms
like we are oh shoot at the Depeche Mode
yeah she was there I'll just say she was
there I'm not gonna say what she was
doing or whatever
and you know she had emailed me
a couple of like maybe a couple weeks
ago and said you know just nice and
he's like I still want to you know I
hope we could be friends and blah blah
blah and I'm like yeah of course great
so I see her
and I just walked up and I go hey
and she looked at me and she froze and
her eyes it lit up like I think she was
happy to see me but then goes
hey I hope you have a good time tonight
and I go uh
okay
and I just walked away I could tell she
did not want to engage I should just
tell and then I talked to my buddy and
goes
her boyfriend
was right behind her with her that I
didn't see
and supposedly he was jealous of me
I guess because she talked about our
friendship or I I don't know
that and also if if your ex just kind of
shows up and you're not emotionally
geared up for it she knew it she knew I
was going to be there I mean she knew I
was going to be there I always go every
year and she's probably hoping that
there were enough people there that it
was just it was just kind of like I
didn't know that person it was just so
weird because she's so nice and friendly
and we were we're on great terms but all
of a sudden I was like oh my God why do
I feel like I'm a weirdo here it just
was really awkward and I thought for
sure she'd send me an email the next day
apologizing saying oh my God I'm so
sorry I didn't know what to do because
you know I was with my blah blah and I
didn't get that and I was just like huh
well I'm not reaching out I'm giving you
[ __ ] it that's life that is life it is
it's just it was a fun comfortable
moment and that is a little Slice of
Life but it didn't take me away from
having a great time I had a great time
with my friends and I let it go pretty
quickly it was a good time yeah it was a
good time so hey thanks for being here
Ryan thank you for having me thanks for
watching uh I am Michael Rosenbaum the
Hollywood Hills of California you gotta
read the patrons
but first i'm gonna read the top tier
patrons here we go I couldn't do the
show without you you know that uh thank
you for sticking around you know I
noticed I mean it's sort of like a weird
environment and uh economically and
there's a lot of people that have hung
around and stuck with me and then
there's you know I could see it some
some have left and I'm like oh shoot you
know what could I do to keep him around
I guess it's like you know I hope I'm
not doing anything wrong and I hope
they're sticking around because they
love supporting the podcast and
hopefully it's enough and the patreon
you're enjoying and I try to make the
boxes plentiful if I can shout outs
Nancy D Leah asks Sarah V little Lisa
Yukiko Jill e Brian H Nico P just saw
Brian H at the Depeche Mode concert nice
Nico P Robert B Jason W Sophie M Raj C
Joshua D Jennifer and Stacy L Jamal F
Janelle B Kimberly e Mike e l Don
suprema 99 more Santiago M Chad W Lee n
p Janine R Maya P Maddie s Belinda and
Chris
Dave H correct Sheila G Brad d Ray hey
correct Tabitha T Tom and Liliana hey
Talia M Betsy D Chad d l l Dan
I don't know and big Stevie W Angel
um
Rhiannon C Corey l-k Dev Nexon Michelle
okay hey hey Jeremy r c correct
gavinator David see yes John C B oh
Brandy
l d d yeah yeah just remember David C
John B Brandy D huh you won't Camille
asks Joey M Eugene and Leah Nikki G
Corey Patricia Heather L Jake B Megan T
Mel s Orlando C Carolyn R Christine S I
don't know if uh Kristen was on there
Christian Kia you on there I'm just
saying your name anyway because I love
her Sarah s Eric H Shane RMR Andrew M
zaduichi 77 Oracle Karina and Amanda are
Amanda s gen B Kevin e Stephanie K Lina
82 Jarrell Billy ass ADHD rocks Todd
Luna r
and I believe that's all I have
also want to say if you I I think at
this point probably at the end of the
episode The Patron people have left and
the patrons are sticking around a lot a
lot of times yeah yeah so guys I love
you I don't know what else to say thank
you for sticking with me and sticking
with the podcast hopefully I'm doing
this at least till next July or August
so hopefully if hopefully we'll stick
around hopefully we'll get to do another
year after that
we'll see but thanks for your help from
the Hollywood Hills in Hollywood
California I'm Micah Rosenbaum I'm Ryan
Tejas
wave of the camera Ryan bye we love you
and remember it Ryan yeah oh what always
hold on to small no no
what be be good to yourself be good to
yourself be good to yourself it's most
important it's hard sometimes just be
good to yourself give yourself a break
we'll see you next week
[Music]